son los rostros del desastre causado por
el volcán semeru
importaba más
al principio pensé que era la explosión
de una bomba y de repente era severo en
erupción y arrojando cenizas volcánicas
y
de repente todo estaba oscuro como si
fuera a destruir la tierra tan sácale
como hosni allá al menos unas 1300
personas fueron evacuadas para evitar
más muertes en la lista de afectados se
encuentran mujeres embarazadas heridas
según la agencia de mitigación de
desastres
mi segundo hijo estaba en la escuela lo
busqué y me enteré que su escuela estaba
destruida pero por suerte sobrevivió y
no sabía dónde estaba mi esposo pero
apareció luego él se cayó y se hizo un
corte en la frente todo fue destruido
las casas de mis parientes la casa de
mis suegros todo se fue
hasta que el volcán se me dio entró en
erupción familiares de los heridos
desaparecidos y fallecidos esperan a las
afueras de los hospitales alguna noticia
que les ayuda a conocer el estado o el
paradero de sus seres queridos
ya es tarde por lo que no pudimos sacar
todos los cuerpos lo único que podemos
hacer es recorrer a los heridos muchos
de ellos están gravemente heridos
en las zonas residenciales alrededor del
cráter se han convertido en localidades
fantasmas cubiertas de ceniza volcánica
según la agencia meteorológica de
indonesia se esperan fuertes lluvias
para los próximos tres días lo que
podría complicar los esfuerzos de
evacuación y rescate